australia is on a mission to change its
dirty image
to show its herd global calls to reduce
emissions
to listen to voters that demanded tough
and immediate action
this shift post-election is night and
day pre-election for several years it
felt like we're in the wind wilderness
with renewable energy now hope sweeping
through the country
these batteries store solar energy
powering everything from homes to farms
australian now aims to source more than
80 per cent of its electricity from
renewable energy by 2030
[Music]
but the new government isn't rejecting
coal it's the world's second largest
exporter
prices are at a record high
and more than 100 new coal and gas
projects are planned
adding to australia's carbon emissions
business as usual is a relief in a
community where mining is in their blood
you take away the coals coal mines from
here
you take away
half the town basically
you might as well knock it down and
throw it all in the bin how are you good
good got through in the end so which is
good yes
the hunter's new labour mp is confident
australia can keep selling coal to the
world
without undermining its new climate
strategy
we are looking after the world by doing
that by making sure that we have good
quality coal
going to these power stations
but digging up coal and selling coal to
countries abroad how can that be helping
or saving the world so if they don't buy
coal from australia they're just going
to source their coal elsewhere
this valley isn't only known for mining
it's also a major wine growing region
battered by climate change
in 2019 three years of drought exploded
into massive bushfires
smoke smothered the vineyards ruining
the grapes
there's hope the government's new
emissions targets will slow global
warming
but they fall short next to the uk and
europe
should the government be doing more
yeah we need to do more and we can be
doing more
we've seen over the last few years some
of the worst effects of climate change
across australia
in terms of agriculture in terms of
natural disasters and australians went
to the polls and gave a really clear
message to the government that they
expect more action
how australia's environmental record
changes over the next few years
will affect how hot the planet gets
its ambition is to become a global
leader instead of a climate outlier
the world
is waiting to judge
nicole johnston sky news in the hunter
valley